otage du polisario les parents accusent
le temps de la discrétion est passé en
termes ans de baladeur de légers
incidents à stuttgart raymonde arabe il
apaise échanges culturels économiques et
et tente au centre des entretiens
oui à londres les écologistes feront de
la politique jusqu'au printemps
les rendez vous littéraire du journal
d'antenne 2 ce soir didier martin
messieurs bonsoir c'est donc confirmé
c'est bien le front polisario qui a
enlevé avant-hier de nouveaux français
près de zohra tu bien que les sahraouis
pour l'instant n'est encore rien annoncé
l'afer a été aussitôt qualifiée de grave
à paris au ministère des affaires
étrangères il faut dire qu'elle met en
lumière un conflit qui ensanglante
depuis deux ans maintenant toute cette
région comprise entre le maroc l'algérie
et la mauritanie
et vous imaginez bien qu'au milieu des
sables du sahara
la frontière est des plus apprécié en
tout cas nombreux sont ceux qui pensent
que la coupe est pleine maintenant six
mois après l'enlèvement de six français
a joué rate et deux ans après la
disparition de cinq jeunes gens dont les
parents ce matin ont d'ailleurs estimé
devant l'assemblée nationale que le
temps de la discrétion des sites étaient
passés et je crois que personne ne peut
être insensible à l'émotion de l'épousé
de l'un des techniciens 7 cf enlevait
avant-hier hier par un télégramme
11h15 et c'est la société à paris qui
m'a parlé c'est à dire la société qui
vous pouvez vous trouver marine que oui
justement qui m'en a parlé que je
souhaite c'est que le gouvernement
agisse très vite qui ne veut pas comme
ils ont peu moins de mai qui en ont
parlé mais dans bien fait ça traîne
s'entraîner et que l'on y arrive très
vite
je m'attends à tout un tas
je demande à ceux qui ont enlevé mon
mari de me donner les nouvelles de lui
même cité la guerre on n'a pas le droit
de me laisser dans l'ignorance s'est
contre toutes les lois
oui alors je crois que devant cette
émotion tout de suite la question qui se
pose est de savoir pourquoi le front
polisario s'en prend comme ça aux
ressortissants d'une nation la france
qui n'a aucun conflit avec lui une
réponse politique que nous examinons
tout à l'heure avec gérard ce bague mais
il ya aussi une raison technique si je
puis dire et saharouis prennent souvent
les français travaillant en mauritanie
pour dédé sorte de mercenaire
or elle document que nous allons vous
montrer le prouve bien or il s'agit de
coopérants et de techniciens comme les
autres ce train le cordon ombilical de
l'économie mauritanienne le train le
plus long du monde près de 3 km il
transporte dans ses wagons 76 % des
exportations mauritanienne donc des
rentrées en devises de ce pays
c'est en réparant comme ici la voie de
chemin de fer longue de 650 km qui
traverse qu'un désert de sable une
colonne du front polisario a attaqué
quand levée des ouvriers dont les deux
techniciens français
et voilà zou et rate une immense mine à
ciel ouvert
d'ici on extrait chaque année de 10 à 12
millions de tonnes de minerai et pour
assurer l'exploitation
les mauritaniens ont besoin d'une
assistance technique extérieur et
notamment françaises
les efforts que nous fait nous avons
fait est que nous faisons actuellement
pour intensifier la formation
professionnelle et il est évident que
nous aurons encore besoin de faire appel
à du personnel qualifié l'étranger nous
comptons profiter de la mobilité
internationale de ce personnel pour pour
obtenir l'apport indispensable pour nos
exploitations sur 1800 ouvriers il ya
quelques mois il y avait encore 280
français ils sont engagé librement par
la snim la société nationale
industrielle et minière ou société
mauritanienne pour un salaire double de
celui qu'ils auraient en france il
s'expatrie l'entente est parfaite entre
le personnel mauritanien et le personnel
français même si on pense que le
polisario à les complicités à zuera
jusqu'à présent la plupart des gens qui
sont ici et qui sont restées parfois
très longtemps sont toujours su se faire
adopter par les mauritaniens et arrivent
à travailler vraiment en équipe
en fait quand on parle
c'est un travail particulier à faire on
parle surtout ici d'une équipe on dit
faute de quoi elle est composé
l'essentiel c'est que c'est une équipe
qui soit soudé et cette enveloppe qui va
ensemble au travail qui fait un certain
gros les conditions de vie de ces
français expatriés sont évidemment très
dur car ils sont perdus dans une ville
artificielle au milieu du désert
cependant en plus des conditions
financières intéressantes qui leur sont
faites pour venir à zuera il dispose
d'un cadre de vie fait pour rendre moins
dur leurs conditions de travail
maisons préfabriquées préfabriqués bien
équipé et air conditionné cuisine
moderne il pouvait également y venir
avec leurs familles notamment leurs
enfants qui avaient la facilité de
poursuivre leurs études avec un
personnel qualifié
l'un des professeurs que l'on voit sur
ces images est disparu au cours de l'
attaque de zohra ben du 1er mai monsieur
ballot voici
ce reportage a été fait quelques jours
seulement avant cette attaque du 1er mai
et bien sûr depuis un certain nombre de
ces familles à leurs demandes qui ont
été rapatriés en france
nous précisément monsieur bourg de
directeur administratif de la succursale
de la snim cette société à paris l on
peut vous poser un ensemble de questions
notamment sur la sécurité est ce que
tous les français qui partent là bas a
travaillé pour le compte de votre
société connaître les risques qu'ils
encourent et bien comme je voulais dit
tout à l'heure nous expliquons d'une
façon tout à fait précise à tous les
agents que nous recrutons la situation
en mauritanie actuellement tout en leur
expliquant évidemment cette situation
nous leur disons également que nous
essayons avec l'aide des autorités
mauritaniennes d'assurer la sécurité la
plus complète mais elle l'assuré c'est
ainsi que vient nous slim bien sûr ça ne
nous concerne pas si vous voulez mais la
mauritanie et l'armée mauritanienne
s'est installé à zuera tu es on peut
considérer qu'elle soit
la sécurité est assurée on voit ce que
ça donne quand même bien au redémarrage
d'un bruit si enfin je pense que déjà
des journalistes sont venus sur place
ils ont constaté que nous avions
construit un fossé tout autour de la
cité
autour de nos installations également un
fossé qui fait 60 km de long et de loin
en loin sur ce fossé sont installés les
éléments de l'armée mauritanienne et
manque
il faut dire aussi pour l'instant que
robert galley vient de dire que paris
n'envisageait pas pour l'instant de
faire protéger par l'armée les français
qui travaillent en mauritanie dans la
question c'est français le polisario le
plus souvent les propos des mercenaires
à ce que vous pouvez dire si oui ou non
ils n'ont absolument pas des activités
d'espionnage
voyez vous c'est surtout l'objet de ma
visite de ce soir et je voudrais pas que
ces travailleurs qui sont en mauritanie
et qu'ils étaient des travailleurs en
france et qui sont allés en mauritanie
justement pour beaucoup de raisons
d'abord parce que les conditions de
travail sont la plus intéressante on a
beau nous la montre plus de
responsabilités et puis il ya un aspect
est également financier qui n'est pas
négligeable et les conditions de vie
qu'on leur offre également sont bonnes
mais ce sont des travailleurs qui
exercent leur métier et qui sont allés
là-bas exclusivement pour cela ils ont
aussi un rôle de formation du personnel
mauritanien et je pense que tout cela
confirme que ce sont ce ne sont que des
travailleurs et seulement cela
merci pour votre témoignage je me tourne
vers nous maintenant gérard ce mag
quelle est la stratégie la vraie
stratégie du front polisario pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils s'en prend technicien
français d'avoir ce qu'il faut préciser
c'est que dans cette région du monde il
ya une véritable guerre un véritable
conflit armé qui oppose le front
polisario qui est une armée de guerriers
rose qui se bat pour ce qu'elle estime
être son droit et qui se bat contre le
maroc et contre la mauritanie la
stratégie militaire du front polisario
est la suivante elle s'attaque depuis
quelques mois au maillon le plus faible
de cette entente entre le maroc et la
mauritanie la mauritanie est un immense
pays de désert où l'armée est assez
faible
donc maintenant pour soutenir la
mauritanie le maroc est obligé d'envoyer
ses troupes ces soldats marocains
environ trente mille actuellement
engagée entre le sahara et de mauritanie
sont donc disperser et il est maintenant
beaucoup plus facile au front polisario
de les attaquer dans des postes isolés
et on voit depuis déjà plusieurs mois
que les opérations du front polisario
ont obtenu un certain succès alors les
français parce que il ya évidemment un
but diplomatique
c'est faire pression sur le gouvernement
français car le front polisario estime
que la france est engagée dans ce
conflit comme engagés dans ce conflit
parce que la france fournit des armes et
à la mauritanie et aux marques
il est vrai qu'il y à un accord qui est
d'ailleurs en cours d'exécution avec le
maroc pour la fourniture d'avions mirage
d'ailleurs très prochainement les
premiers mirage vont arriver au maroc et
il ya également des livraisons de chars
et de blindés pour la mauritanie et pour
le maroc
donc le président giscard d'estaing à
illies à cela quelques mois indiqué
qu'ils étaient aussi contre la création
de mini états et notamment contre la
création d'un état sahraoui mais la
france n'a jamais reconnu cette année
absolument mais les sahraouis site
d'autres exemples comme par exemple
territoire de djibouti le territoire des
comores qui ont obtenu leur indépendance
enfin tout ça c'est de la diplomatie et
même si les sahraouis sont dans leur
droit
il faut quand même voir qu'ils sont en
infraction avec ce qu'on appelle les
conventions internationales de genève
en ce qui concerne les prisonniers et là
on ne peut pas admettre que le front
polisario pour l'instant ne donne aucune
nouvelle aux familles de ces prisons
sachez aussi que deux jeunes françaises
ont été assassinées au nord-yémen de
jeunes mannequins autre enterrement
autre climat
48 heures après les funérailles
nationales de reims martin schleyer
célébrer solennellement devant tous les
dirigeants de l'état allemand
un autre cimetière de sauvegarde était
le théâtre de l'inhumation des trois
leaders la fraction armée rouge
andreas baader et ses deux amis climat
lourd tendu rendu même un petit peu
irréel par la tenue des sympathisants
venus assister à l'enterrement
la plupart avaient le visage dissimulé
par un foulard et le tout sur fond de
mitraillettes de police montée et deux
garde-frontières en hélicoptère michel
meyer
discrète mais omniprésente la police
était installé dans la coulisse de
l'enterrement d'andreas baader et de ses
amis sa présence n'avait pas
impressionné quelques 600 à 800
sympathisants des terroristes et
allemands voile en lorraine où leur
détermination de poursuivre leur guerre
contre la société ouest allemande ou
exprimant au contraire une douleur nu
c'est moins de 30 ans du gauchisme et de
l'anarchie entendait confirmer leur
survivance
parmi ceux qui étaient venus les
observer le cinéaste paul curlander et
ses cameramen mais au delà du spectacle
et d'un événement journalistique
mondiale qui avait attiré au moins 300
reporters
il y avait surtout la douleur de parents
écartelée entre leur attachement
paternelle ou maternelle et le refus de
la violence surtout celle de leurs
enfants
pour la plupart des extrémistes
politiques présents il s'agissait plutôt
de célébrer ici les obsèques d'amy
idéologiques qu'ils tenteront désormais
de présenter comme étant des victimes
d'un fascisme allemand qu'ils affirment
renaissance il est très difficile de
prévoir l'écho de leurs proclamations
dans une allemagne fédérale
choqué par la récente vague de terreur
il reste qu'avec le départ des familles
et notamment de la mer d'andreas baader
le calme du cimetière de jute gars a
fait place à des accrochages entre
sympathisants et policiers
outre-rhin la violence n'a pas dit son
dernier mot
puis pendant ce temps-là l' enquête se
poursuit de l'autre côté de la frontière
en france une vaste opération de
ratissage a été déclenchée ce matin en
moselle
une enquête qui n'est pas du goût de
tout le monde la fédération alsacienne
parti communiste a demandé que les
policiers allemands cesse de travailler
sur le territoire français christian
bonnet de son côté évoquant le drame
devant la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale a réaffirmé qu'il
souhaitait voir se brise et je cite la
complicité inconsciente du silence lors
d'attentats ou d'actes de violence
raymond barre à budapest depuis ce matin
après washington moscou est bonne et
avant pékin en ministre français avait
voulu se rendre dans un pays peut
visiter jusqu'à lors par les dirigeants
français et il avait au moins une bonne
raison de se rendre à budapest son
épouse peu de gens le savent est
d'origine hongroise budapest ce matin
guerre guy lazar président du conseil
hongrois accueil raymond barre en visite
officielle en hongrie garde d'honneur
marchera cosy du soleil sur les drapeaux
les uniformes et les cuivres un petit
air de fête pour ce qu'on peut
considérer comme des retrouvailles
franco hongroise
outre monsieur lazhar qui est le numéro
2 on croit raymond barre verra demain le
numéro un
diano scada au programme de cette visite
resserrer les relations franco hongroise
traditionnellement bonnes mais un peu
vague et distant du ajoutant que
monsieur bart est accompagné de mesures
aussi ministre du commerce extérieur de
monsieur deniau secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères qui auront des
entretiens très approfondie sur les
échanges commerciaux et sur les
relations culturelles
donc pour raymond barre un voyage police
un voyage politique qui se double pour
madame barre d'un voyage sentimental
hongroise d'origine madame bâ a quitté
son pays alors qu'elle était encore une
étudiante mais sa soeur elle est restée
à budapest qui est mariée elle est là
sur l'aérodrome et le protocole 7 pour
quelques secondes à l'émotion
que ressort-il de cette première journée
que les relations franco hongroise
s'inscrivent parfaitement dans un
contexte européen de détente car ces
relations sont calmées confiante mais
économiquement si relations sont
insuffisantes comme messieurs lazare et
bars ont pu s'en convaincre cet après
midi la france n'est que le onzième
fournisseurs et le 11e clients de la
hongrie derrière la suisse et même
derrière le brésil on va essayer demain
de faire mieux
très brièvement noël mamère une dernière
information cette affaire devant lui
nous apprenons qu'une réunion
exceptionnelle a eu lieu cet après-midi
en fin d'après-midi à l'elysée autour du
président de la république
rassemblant le ministre les affaires
étrangères le ministre de la défense le
ministre de la coopération et le chef
d'état-major des armées on a donc tout
lieu de penser qu'il s'agit des deux
otages pris par le polisario
mardi il ya la politique en quelques
brèves le budget de l'éducation devant
les députés
et à cette occasion une précision
intéressante de rené haby dans deux ans
quand la réforme atteindra la classe de
4e
les élèves pourront choisir à la fois
des options techniques de langues
vivantes et de langues anciennes mais
autour d'un tronc commun paul dijoux a
lancé ce matin les états généraux de la
jeunesse une consultation nationale des
jeunes doit leur permettre d'exprimer
leurs problèmes leurs aspirations et
leurs revendications jacques chirac
optimiste dans une interview à notre
confrère la croix
juge son mouvement le rpr en pleine
expansion nous avons aujourd'hui dit-il
largement passé le cap des 500 mille
adhérents et puis les écologistes en
campagne et leur tour mais avec une
petite idée derrière la tête
ce n'est pas l'élection pour l'élection
c'est le désir de peser sur le scrutin
pour que leurs idées soient prises en
considération
brice lalonde l'écologie a une dimension
qui est surtout de local par conséquent
vous avez des milliers et des milliers
d'associations en france et nous
commençons maintenant un processus qui
sera un petit peu lent sans doute de
fusion en quelque sorte en créant une
association qui va disparaître juste
après les élections et on appelle
justement d'ailleurs écologistes sont 18
pour bien montrer que c'est transitoire
éphémère est ce que ces associations
sont toutes du même avis sur un
programme pour les législatives a
programmé que le vide
je crois que oui il ya des convergences
les écologistes certains ont des idées
différentes sur beaucoup de choses mais
cherche plutôt à voir ce qui les unit
alors nous allons vraisemblablement axé
notre notre campagne d'intervention
autour de cinq grands problèmes n'est ce
pas le premier qui nous sommes très très
grave c'est l'écart entre les pays sous
développés et les pays sous développés
dans lequel la france a une très grande
responsabilité
le second c'est la disparition de plus
en plus rapide de toutes les ressources
biologiques les terres cultivables et
arlon les espèces animales et végétales
le troisième c'est la question de
l'énergie c'est à dire qu'il faut
absolument stopper cet engrenage qui
veut que nous consommions toujours de
plus en plus d'énergie avec des énergies
de plus en plus dangereuse
le troisième c'est le gaspillage pur et
simple du travail humain c'est-à-dire le
fait qu' on est on réduit les gens à des
travailleurs etc ont fait produire
n'importe quoi notamment des choses
dangereuses et ruineuse que par exemple
concorde où cela mr automobile par
exemple et enfin le dernier point
c'est ce que nous appelons
l'asservissement de plus en plus grand
des individus des communautés des
régions dans des grands systèmes
centralisés le fait qu' on est victime
un petit peu on perd son autonomie dans
des grands systèmes dans la prise en
charge général dans l'extension de
l'état voilà les cinq grands problèmes
je crois sur lequel les échos bistrot
spectacle et bien voilà un premier
dossier que nous soumettons à brice
lalonde le vieux débat écologique honte
économie et derrière l'économie derrière
le progrès il est souvent des hommes
regardent et boulogne premier port de
pêche français boulogne est bloqué
depuis hier par une quinzaine de patrons
pêcheurs
ils protestent contre l'interdiction de
la pêche au hareng jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
une décision prise par les neuf à
luxembourg pour préserver la race de ces
clips et idc le nom savant des as
prochaine réunion de concertation entre
les pêcheurs et la ministre le 8
novembre puisque nous parlant poisson il
faut que je vous dise que 10 millions
d'esturgeons viennent de mourir ces deux
derniers jours en iran à la suite d'une
inondation
je vis à cause du caviar et de la
proximité de noël quand un produit qui
va monter andré bergeron est déçu mais
pas désespérée raymond barre a dit non à
sa proposition d'une cinquième semaine
de congés payés
mais le leader de force ouvrière pense
que de toute façon ça finira par se
faire un jour ou l'autre
sept revendications que nous avons
présentées nous paraît juste
d'abord parce que 30% des salariés de
l'industrie du commerce et des services
en bénéficient déjà
il n'y a donc pas de raison que les
autres ne l'est pas d'autre part
économiquement parlant
la chose est supportable et socialement
elle est indiscutablement nécessaire
c'est pourquoi nous n'abandonnons pas
nous allons rencontrer le premier
ministre le 4 novembre
j'ai demandé audience à monsieur
françois ceyrac nous allons par
conséquent reprendre la question et je
reste confiant léo finiront par aboutir
georges marchais débouté de sa plainte
en usage de faux contre minutes et la
nation socialiste le tribunal n'a pas
retenu ce délit selon lui n'est pas
constitué problème était de savoir si le
document qui certifiait que le
secrétaire général du pc avait
volontairement travailler en allemagne
pendant la guerre était vrai ou faux il
y aura sans doute une bataille de
juristes après cette décision
certains d'entre eux disent déjà que si
monsieur marche avait porté plainte pour
diffamation et non pas pour usage de
faux il aura gagné les avocats toute
façon du dirigeant communiste ont fait
appel est immédiatement d'ailleurs une
réaction du pcf le pouvoir 10e le pc
cherchent à porter atteinte à georges
marchais et au parti tout entier
en attendant georges marchais entreprend
à la vaste campagne d'explication du pc
il y a dans quelques minutes sans doute
il va prendre la parole à vitry sur
seine
au cours d'un rassemblement que vous
voyez ici en direct organisée par la
fédération communiste du val de marne un
extrait de ce discours dans le dernier
journal de gérard holtz serpent de mer
qui agite tour à tour les milieux
politiques et les milieux sportifs
les concours de pronostics et bien ils
font à nouveau leur apparition sur le
devant de la scène avec leurs partisans
de toujours le député républicain
bernard bapst remo relance la
proposition proposition qui sera
débattue le 7 novembre à l'occasion du
budget du secret d'état aux sports mais
qui d'ores et déjà partage en deux le
palais bourbon
chez nos voisins italiens les pronostics
sur les matchs de football font fureur
le système s'appelle le tocard
on y gagne des sommes importantes en
france depuis des années déjà les avis
sont partagés
pour ou contre monsieur bernard
destremeau vient de se tarir un petit
succès la commission des finances de
l'assemblée s'est enfin prononcé en
adoptant son amende
le football est le sport le plus
populaire il ya un million trois cent
mille licenciés et il n'y a pas de
concours de pronostics c'est très
curieux parce que dans toute l'europe ce
concours existe n'existe pas en france
ni en albanie alors ce que j'appellerais
l'économie du système consiste à jouer
sur le sport le plus populaire pour en
tirer des ressources qui bénéficieront
ainsi sur le point qui bénéficieront à
tous les sports c'est à dire que
l'athlétisme la natation la course à
pied qui sont des sports qui ont dès
qu'on appelle des vertus éducatives et
qui n'ont pas de recettes bénéficieront
des recettes provenant
du concours de pronostics sur les matchs
sur canal
bolt a péché
tout même là on parie sur des êtres
humains est ce que vous ne trouvez pas
le procédé à ces indélicats oui on parie
sur les équipes se vendent les concours
pour le football on parie sur les onze
joueurs de l'équipe
on parie pas sur tel ou tel joueur et
puis ceci étant dit en passant quand on
joue au tiercé si vous voulez on joue
certes le cheval non jumeaux shimshon
yves saint martin si pour certains
députés
le baromètre du palais-bourbon marque le
beau fixe
il n'en est pas de même pour certains
autres membres du parlement se prononce
contre
il déclare notamment que les ressources
normale devrait favoriser le
développement de la pratique sportive à
l'exclusion de toute autre finalité est
ce que l'on va simplement renforcer tous
les vices du sport professionnel est ce
que l'on risque de ne pas devoir la les
compétition faussée par ce concours de
pronostics
je n'ai pas l'impression ce soit une
bonne chose et pour ma part je trouve
assez immoral de parier sur les
résultats de ce qui devrait être des
justes pour crif
nous sommes contre les paris sur les
activités humaines
cela renforcerait l'emprise de l'argent
sur le sport notamment sur un sport
puisqu'on parle du football est sans
aucun doute au détriment de l' équilibre
avec les autres activités physiques et
sportives dans notre pays en vérité il
nous semble que le bruit fait autour de
cette question a pour but de faire
diversion de faire diversion au fait que
le seul record que monsieur d'y jouer pu
inscrire à son actif c'est d'avoir fait
baisser le budget de la jeunesse et des
sports en dessous des 7 millièmes du
budget national
alors verra-t-on en france un
financement extrabudgétaires du sport ou
conservera ton la formule actuelle
quitte à trouver plus tard une meilleure
formule de financement
la commission des finances a dit oui au
concours de pronostics
les députés dans leur ensemble
décideront bientôt
donc très précisément le 7 novembre le
tribunal civil d'avignon n'aime pas la
farce
en tout cas pas celle que gilbert
allemand mettait dans ses boules de paix
comme de pétanque pour mieux s'approcher
du cochonnet 15 ans d'interdiction de
concours de boules pour s'être servi de
ces boules truqués en compétition pour
mieux comprendre comment une boule peut
être trafiquées propose d'observer la
fabrication d'une boule normal une
industrie que nous envient de nombreux
pays en effet la boule d'acier
inoxydable a déjà séduit
vingt-et-une nation de l'angleterre au
canada en passant par l'australie
l'afrique les états unis et tous les
pays d'europe
les conditions sont presque réunies pour
l'entrée de la pétanque ou jeux
olympiques
pour obtenir ces boules par fait objet
d'une rare précision il ne faut pas
moins de dix huit opérations de
fabrication et 10 opérations de contrôle
il existe aujourd'hui en france une
dizaine d'usinés spécialisées qui
produisent un million de boules par an
soit un chiffre d'affaires de 4
milliards de centimes
le poids d'une boule est variable mais
se situe aux environs de 700 grammes
certains joueurs plus truand que les
autres les trucs et leur donne une somme
il était plus grande
en introduisant à l'intérieur 20 30 ou
40 grammes de mercure
on voit là une boulevard soult mercure
les avantages d'abord les freiner dans
les terrains en pente
elle file beaucoup plus droit troisième
avantage lorsque l on tire bien elle
permet de réaliser des carreaux plus
facilement pour détecter une boule
truqués voici un appareil très simple il
en existe d'autres qui sont beaucoup
plus sophistiqué et je vais tenter de
vous faire une démonstration
la boule normal doit toucher le ressort
que voici
et revenir pratiquement à son point de
départ l'autre non
la boule normal la voici la voilà ce
qu'on fait on pousse
ça touche et ça revient au point de
départ
ça c'est la boule normal la boule noire
cela les trucs et c'est georges les
goûts qui me l'a donné il ya du mercure
dedans 20 grammes de mercure
cela pousse voyez je vais pousser plus
fort que l'autre
et malgré cela elle revient pas au point
de départ voilà il faut quand même dire
qu'il ya 10 millions de joueurs de
pétanque en france il ya très peu de
boue le truc pour terminer et bien
poursuivre notre série de portraits
littéraire alain gillot-pétré vous
présente aujourd'hui didier martin son
dernier roman un garçon en l'air fait
partie de la liste ce que l'on appelle
les goncourt à bhl comme d'ailleurs son
avant dernier roman l'année dernière
alors on pourrait se dire qu'être en
compétition pour le prix goncourt c'est
une chance une occasion d'avoir de gros
tirage de voulait le voir cette réalité
est bien différente
écoutez
didier martin en dix ans sept livres et
sept romans un homme jeune et discret à
l'abri des scandales et des livres
racoleur un grand talent et de petits
tirages
c'est le plus écrivain de nos jeunes
auteurs c'est dire qu'il ne vit pas de
sa plume
une âme une voiture du ministre n'est
pas moi la partie à une agence de
location de voitures de grande remise
pour laquelle je travaille depuis
longtemps pour gagner ma vie
autrement dit vous avez des métiers oui
j'ai celui ci qui mon gagne pain est en
fait le vrai métier
plus qu'un métier même c'est d'être
écrivain vous êtes d'abord il a bien sûr
d'ailleurs j'ai fait partir du moment où
j'ai décidé d'écrire
c'était ballon bon service militaire d'
assez longtemps j'ai cherché j'ai décidé
de ne pas avoir un vrai métier de ne pas
continuer mes études je voulais alors
j'ai cherché des petits boulots
différentes choses jusqu'à ce que je
trouve ça qui me laisse pas mal de temps
libre parce que c'est je suis pas payée
au mois donc je peux arrêter quand je
veux ralentir ça me laisse l'esprit
entièrement libre petite amie quand je
suis dehors je conduis je rencontre des
gens de tous les pays un peu tous les
genres et c'est ce qui me plaît c'est à
dire ça fait dix ans que je fais ça
alors qu'avant jamais changé plusieurs
fois mais pourquoi ne peut-on pas vivre
de sa plume quand on a du talent à qui
la faute
je crois que le talent et le l'argent
qu'on gagne n'ont pas grand chose à voir
l'argent c'est bien avec les tirages
pour moi jusqu'à maintenant ça va être
disant que se publie 7,3 man publié au
début les tirages était minable le monde
records dont celui de l'année dernière
c'est une 4725 exemplaires en un an se
trouvait comme ça je crois que personne
ne sait même pas les éditeurs pourquoi
un livre un écrivain va marcher
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment de
continuer à prendre votre métier ou
d'exploiter un capital pour vous
possédez déjà
non je fais les probables j'ai
l'impression de livre en livre j'arrive
à mieux maîtriser les idées de départ à
mieux les agences est allé à droite à
gauche sans perdre le fil principal
certainement quand je jette un coup
d'oeil mais les premiers livres ceux qui
ont refusé les premiers accepter
certains que je me sens plus à l'aise ça
me satisfait mieux à chaque fois que
j'ai fini un livre qui commence
d'ailleurs à en voir les défauts il faut
que j'évite ça encore une fois tous vos
livres paraissent en septembre pour les
prix ou corps et après ça c'est le dit
ça dépend de l'éditeur les trois
derniers sont sortis en septembre
puisque les premiers noms au contraire
il sortait en dehors de la période des
prix parce que je pense qu on devait
leur accorder aucune chance et si vous
n'aviez jamais de prix vous seriez un
écrivain quand même un écrivain à part
entière où lui sera certainement ce soit
que j'aime faire j'organise ma vie en
fonction de ça je secours principal
plaisir c'est vraiment ma raison de
vivre puisque nous y sommes le rsa lui
et le petit livre de notre dessinateur
adoré gus qui lui n'est pas en
compétition pour le goncourt mais qui
est bien drôle à trois je saute
saluons aussi pendant que nous y sommes
celui de paul lefèvre que je n'ai pas
sous la main mais qui est lui le recueil
de tous ses points de vue aux antennes
relais le tiercé maintenant disputer
aujourd'hui à saint cloud le 4 le 12 et
le 27 je vous laisse découvrir les
rapports sur votre écran et puis le
sujet de conversation de la journée la
préparation du grand pont de la
toussaint que nous faisons à chaque fois
voici les conseils du ministère de
l'équipement ne partez pas demain vous
le voyez entre 15h et 21h et après
demain samedi entre 6 heures et 15
heures
en tout cas sont des heures de départ de
grandes villes très déconseillée par le
réentendre tout un temps utile des
retours
la météo maintenant pour demain temps
très nuageux le matin du sud-ouest à la
normandie avec un déplacement vers l'est
de ce mauvais temps sur la méditerranée
et les halles qu'il faudra surtout
redouter des averses orageuses parfois
fortes températures sans grand
changement
voilà la dernière édition et à 23h30
présenté par gérard holtz juste après le
grand échiquier faute à tout une très
bonne soirée et j'espère vous retrouver
demain soir